vas-y aura soit sur le côté viens avec
moi eric voilà bien là mon chéri mathieu
d'alors tu fais une entrée mon chéri un
fait une entrée outils di maria
semerjian aller bastien aulas [ __ ]
choc ça va être chouette pas dans le
coin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais son tir
c'est moi qui vais d'animer série
malheureusement ne peut plus vraiment
être avec tout puisque je fais les
audiences exceptionnelles et que la
chaîne m'a demandé de le remplacer et
que j'ai accepté je suis en blanc la
virginité l'audience c'est parti
à la joie à la joie de voir la
délimitation
un chroniqueur mana et louis
est ce qu'il est loin un peu ringard non
mais l'assemblage allait acheter suite
quoi maintenant mais je t'explique ouais
j'étais chez intermarché
non mais j'étais hier chez nietzsche est
encore chez lidl était de retour chez
lidl l'animé les résultats de la
présidentielle ou allemands times en
outaouais la jeunesse que toi déjà tu as
atteint marché bat bien sûr je n'ai
jamais remarcher les notaires tablent à
savoir et mon bébé je peux te dire j'ai
fait les p assé l'arrêt parfait ça tombe
bien parce que je sais c'est mal
apparemment
apparemment monsieur me croisaient le
fer avec
tak tak tak attention
ça va me sens à l'aise et je suis direct
à l'aise un
peu non alors je vais te dit tu te rends
là est ce que tu te sens bien très bien
tu as a prévenu jeudi soir j'essaie je
suis très en forme
on a beaucoup beaucoup misé sur ce prime
c'est à dire
mais c'est sur ce principe que j'y crois
beaucoup ah ouais moi aussi c'est aussi
à moi aussi comment tu te sens lui ils
ont maintenant envie de faire monter les
spectacles 10 mois à combien j'aimerais
faire quoi être plus petits sont mixées
magnifique un nombre exceptionnel ça non
déjà les frères tu vas les toits des
gros films safari tout safari c'est nul
à chier j'adore safari ck oui c'est vrai
que j'adore c'est un ami non mais c'est
vrai que certains énoncés bien ça arrive
mais c'est beaucoup passé je crois que
c'est l'autre safari moi je te dis rien
cinq cent mille cinq cent mille
5 ménagères heureux ouais bah tu te dis
ouais tu seras heureux vendredi quand tu
es heureux qu est ce que tu fais moi tu
bouffée
d'optimisme mais c'est une fille
qui m'a donné ce bonheur non tombe de ne
pas emmerder ton air de servir
j'aimerais qu'on bat benjamin castaldi
ab boichut
dr house on n'en peut plus là mais sans
déconner non mais regardez le
franchement regardez le
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il ya
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention
du ghana
c'est cela
la dent nautique et
le ministre a fait une entrée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait le gardien du stade
normalement attendu dyson astana
toujours agathe quand même
un message ou non mais il sait pas
arriver le gars ne fait pas rêver
mathieu diriger c'est le seul mec qui
s'est cassé la jambe sa moto à l'arrêt
non mais c'est quoi
non mais c'est vrai mais il n'a pas de
chance la patience et la chaire ivoire
était juste pas là quand on a la
malchance est une faute professionnelle
à richert loggia le gars il a pris quand
même une région de salta la moto à la
reine je n'ai
appris beaucoup dans la réponse à
l'iphone n'y avait pas la béquille mais
oui mais en plus j'aime en moi dit
j'étais à 150
c mon palace est terminé
son lourd mais excellent tu sois arrivé
avant la fin du générique ou
au tessin les toits des eaux j'ai quand
même toit et un de tous les
[Rires]
thèmes bien temps de minutes on va faire
rage au jeu placé capte mal de bourget
mais la jambe c'est là qu'elle sait là
s'arrête non mais c'est pourquoi c'est
la droite laquelle celle annoncée la
droite attend la droite non non vous ne
m'arrête je t'interdis traite à tabarre
y est ouvert à bon mr bah ouais il
ya le tout petit oiseau
il ya ya ya ya ya ya les
cas on peut y aller ça va pas durer
jusqu'en corse alcool jeunes c'est un
triste spectacle
basi bah oui mon voyage génériques alors
il fait l'entrée de plus loin au nom
basés ici c'est ça qui est marrant
abadie
la firme merde allons-y halo 2 3
c'est vrai
ce vent tourner ce soir
quoi qu'il arrive je serai toujours
vivant je serai toujours la même avec
une jambe même sans jambes je serai plus
qu'ils font
[Applaudissements]
sans rigoler il a été très bon et je me
demande toujours s'il n'est pas
meilleure avec une victoire ça
je te prête à
attendre il est fait mais toi sur mandat
voilà voilà vous êtes mon épaule je fais
bien tu vas pouvoir l'animer cette
émission d'ora belle aya je te ramène
tes mon frère et évite de me pousser
comme ça
toi ça va jeter oui ce sera ta
c'est pas mal hein c'est pas mal et aux
arrêtés ne pas de bagarre bonsoir
doucement pas de bagarre allez allez
allez dans une heure il est assis
[Rires]
et c'est bon les cherry bomb l'instant
c'est pas mal hein les dehors on voit
que vous avez du métier je propose qu'on
voit qu'en amérique très vite ah ouais
mais eric ya un tricheur regard des
rails tellement fatigué qui boit
on voit que t'es pathétique
heureusement heureusement c'est con mais
ça me coûte ça ouais hein je sais
combien ça coûte un regard sur moi alors
tous à vos renvoi c'est tout sourire je
crois qu'ils les mecs je reviens je
crois je crois qu'il y avait un
happening de prévu ah ah oui mais
attends c'est dans quoi c'est dans tout
ça c'est
loupé oui manger des insectes pourrait
permettre d'améliorer
les animateurs
un peu ça devient gênant à mes chers
grecs c'est pas mal ouais ouais vous
allez manger s'il peut tout bouffer dire
regardez la ligue 2 vous semblez un
criquet
non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
vous la venue comme ça d'un coup l'ol et
c'est là je vous revois dira cricket
c'est quoi qui les attend la bouteille
tu le rapt alors éric vas-y mon chéri
allez vas-y eric il voit le micro à
tuvalu
badiou jury que chez toi ici
l'autre c'est l'autre c'est l'autre tu
crois que c'est l'autre
à lesparre être excellent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
knowlesi sa soeur
ok 2 à
bienvenue à 12h07 ce soir nous avec
mathieu de laval
ban
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est matt l'ambiance
après niveau vocabulaire contrarié parce
que c'est vrai que
moi l'énergie est là ah oui avait bien
un truc un petit truc ringard qui l'a
fait roi c'est quoi le petit clin d'oeil
caméras chez
lui c'est pareil
arrête de me faire des camps même suisse
alémanique est c'est à dire moi qui
tiens à bas le clin d'oeil au fait c'est
quoi ouais bah genre quoi vous des
torrents de boue fait quoi toi tu veux
juste alors attendez chanteranne dans
ses toiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu crois que mes danser comme un connard
en effet cela fait deux heures que ce
torse comato j'avais fait ça une fois là
bas c'est pas possible on le voit
partout l'un des bassistes un petit clin
d'oeil et le clin d'oeil ça veut dire
c'est bon quoi n'eo ket tu m'a bouffé le
coquin
n'en fait pas plus c'est ok brochet
corps qui sait pour flotter bon pour moi
c'est ok c'est quoi un incident t on
retourner bancaire quand on est peu de
chose à skis d'or devant toi
tu es donc ans à mykonos avec toi alors
moi je t'explique sanaa il a dit que
j'étais venu animer rostain tout le
monde gagne à tout le monde que je
serais pas là